hey see go and brush top I try to do the
jacksepticeye have my voice is not that
great okay well welcome back everybody
for another one Edgar's here - I mean
Treecko I just died
what a great intro let's keep going now
if I've heard yet from my friends who's
also playing this game I have friends I
know it's unbelievable
whoa look at this this is pretty this I
feel like something bad is gonna happen
if you jump down there and I'm not
talking about the camera angles okay
we're getting attacked all right I'll
help you trick a [ __ ] that worked
charged in - thanks game you [ __ ]
troll okay we're getting attacked what
do I do all that one has a [ __ ]
shield that [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's ah you got me
ow how does he know not to hit me [ __ ]
that's right oh [ __ ] my foot got him
Treecko oh he has a shield again you
[ __ ] when Aiden alright let's get up and
trick on make sure oh my god I love
jumps what the [ __ ] is happening there
they're dead they're definitely dead I
don't know
how you don't see this there dad
I would get up on his head and do it but
he doesn't [ __ ] it okay oh he wasn't
even dead
what the [ __ ] hahaha okay alright I'm
back back in action I feel great now
let's just remove this toothpick Basha
bah
okay great big wide we did that now
where were we
what's happening all right so that's
which he needs to fall down somehow whoa
look at that it's so [ __ ] beautiful
this game is amazing okay so he's
looking up there we need to go up there
I get it now Treecko can you get me up
there buddy I'm back with a lot more
energy I was so [ __ ] tired yesterday
I am stuck at this [ __ ] puzzle can
you believe I played ten minutes and I
was like nope I don't know how to solve
this I think I figured it out just aside
quit playing though so let's let's see
if my theory is correct he's got a spear
in his ass dude I am so sorry bro
I didn't mean I didn't see that you've
been cheating on me huh there we go
now he's gonna do it I don't know that's
kind of stupid he was already doing it
really oh now I get it now I'm doing it
right now we can get this [ __ ] thing
some parts man that kind of that kind of
pissed me up I think that's kind of
stupid wow this is going great
okay now we have a catapult thing that's
[ __ ] awesome who doesn't love a good
cat apart I don't that's cuz you don't
have thumbs yeah [ __ ] chicken leg
what the [ __ ] did you say there [ __ ] do
you one minute is he gonna catapult me
up no [ __ ] way that's cool though
that's [ __ ] awesome
he's curious Jay says okay I see what's
gonna happen and that's pretty [ __ ]
cool all right I'm excited about this
one I hope I don't hit my head come on
boy I want to go to space I want to go
to the moon oh I'll send you the [ __ ]
worst don't you worry baby okay then
I'm waiting please thank you nice one
you hit it you really hit it good job
just do it you're really starting to
make me feel like Edgar Jesus Christ
yes yes yes do it there it is
thank you what's that fun I wish I could
do that that looked like a real fun time
you're welcome Poots you know what her
next time just tell me what you want to
do and I'll do it
Jesus Christ shut up shut up me
Jabba to
oh wow there's a lot of levers I didn't
realize I [ __ ] let's open all of them
you know what bucket life's handing you
your levers to make doors open hopefully
there's nothing bad hey let's pick this
one this one is Breanna this looks
pretty it's a bird
there's so many bird oh it's so bright
oh now we're triggering him oh my god
ah so bright ah it's an [ __ ] talking
to me I'll wait there it is
okay great Rico good good one here's
peyote
now wait that's you okay great awesome
let's go in one of these that doesn't
look like it's right let's go that's not
it either this one it is for sure I'm
sure of it great oh it's so bright but
it's so pretty
I'm coming Jesus Christ oh my feet are
getting slippery look at this so cool I
just love the heights and the scenery in
this game I just love it I cannot have
enough of it I'll be like you can take a
screenshot at any moment and it's just
it just feels like a wall thing what are
you doing
I'm gonna go on top of me I don't
[ __ ] trust anything what you're gonna
try to me this game is about trust
come on just go there's dank weed over
there where
we're pleased I haven't smoked in days
it's been 20 minutes see the jump
Treecko oh boy that's a tricky one trick
I'll be careful now here I go here I go
yep very nice you did good boy
what are you doing you're going up again
no we're not going up again go in
okay okay okay please okay fine I'll go
you can sit there and fart shut up maybe
I had beans a Heisenberg a make me part
me that's hilarious
okay I told you there's water part
coming up I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
Mike
whatever we got here pretty everything's
pretty except Rico's butthole have you
guys noticed when he jumps his tail goes
up and you can see his butthole I don't
know why Hey look at him we got some
food who's been a good boy who's been a
good butt Oh me me me me me me me me me
me me me
mine mine that's mine that's mine give
it to me
oh he wanted me to pet him oh I'm so
sorry
you [ __ ] and a handsome look at
everything cute he changes his behavior
a little bit it's kind of Awesome come
on nice all right it looks like we need
to go out oh my god solving those
puzzles so easy way to me this game is
too easy
oh my god Hey look at that this is cool
whoa
Oh dime okay hope there's no sharks or I
can dime now who there's something very
far down there do you see it no because
my skirt isn't doing but bit bit bit bit
bit bitter bitter bitter bitter bitter
bitter bitter bitter the bib how do i
zoom it up okay now he's really
struggling I think we need Trika
drinking beer record that's how you
sound pigs that's how you sound like
alright here we go here we go I'm ready
I'm ready
all right it's been a while cannonball
whoa oh my god oh jeez it smells like
wet cat now shut up I'm not a kid I'm a
catfish dog salmon okay no you need to
go back in trigger but I'm wet is it
gonna shake himself off oh [ __ ] what's
that
okay all right back it back at it again
go back in don't go back in man trick
are you getting horny
jeez those are growing fast there it is
what the [ __ ] that's so random look at
that pot hole look at the bottle air it
is that's a butthole I was looking for
what is happening right now
oh he failed it looks kinda like a VHS
tape underwater it's kind of weird
oh he's sad now oh I didn't pull the
lever that's why I just didn't [ __ ]
work this is all my fault
fantastic
what the [ __ ] are you kidding me that
was a I'm so stupid
I deserve [ __ ] spanking hopefully I'm
still hanging on see now it's open okay
I am so sorry I am an idiot
I am complete and outer [ __ ] more of
it thank you everyone
we're subscribing and watching this
shitty-ass bless playing I'm trying my
best okay I'm sorry
we're dead whoa that is cool I saw how
the light reflects nice nice one Pierce
how about you blame your [ __ ] self
instead of the game huh
[ __ ] idiot you're gonna do that shaky
thing oh oh geez what's this last time
you took a shower
shut up say mr. your problem okay we
managed to swing through there
I suppose we it's just jumping time man
you drive fast there you go
like a little submarine here wait you
could just do that oh my god
Jesus Christ ya [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll wait
here gotta take a pee okay fine you know
what fine if you find some Heisenberg oh
my god one how did I guess yeah uh-huh
hey actually got it how about they who's
Ben oh there's been a good boy oh my god
me me me me me me me me how about I just
plays it nailed it and it broke
oopsy-daisy you're lucky I felt you're
judging me a lot this episode okay I am
sensing it I don't like it
what's with water temples and video
games what the [ __ ] are you doing what
is happening oh it's you hey what are
your heroin splashes blanks can I join
okay all right
there's a gate there I'm going to okay
dude we can't go now let go
[ __ ] sake it's the exact same puzzle
just go on I didn't ask you to swim down
I really didn't ask for this
you are so [ __ ] annoying how do I
swim up well guess what you [ __ ] can
you have to go here hahahaha I am NOT
swimming I am dancing huh
dancing what up dancing oh hey there's
no ladder there's the ladder oh great
the ladder it broke
maybe Treecko is in the water the water
the lever rises that's kind of cool
puzzle jump in alright here I go
cannonball here we go here we go here we
go that's like very cool puzzle actually
huh huh I really like that one that's
awesome yeah oh we did
this guy does not like to swim up huh
noticing there you go
you did it somehow somehow you managed
to trickle don't go up for [ __ ] sake
man yeah [ __ ] white [ __ ] cat
coming in tricker the water is so nice
let's take a close-up
come on Treecko it's so nice
oh you look shut up you're not naked
come on in come on in everybody
you've done this before so cute okay all
right now we're gonna die you know where
to die bro I'll point you I'll punch you
buddy you don't have to do a thing I
mean you have to do everything at this
point actually I'm the one that don't
okay that's not it this way no this way
this way this way this way okay oh you
found the barrel you found the bear huh
oh my god I feel so great this way this
out Jesus Christ he's so cute in the
water so stupid as well I think he
didn't think you could get dumber don't
go up where's he going
not there
huh right [ __ ] there right [ __ ]
there right [ __ ] there you want to go
right [ __ ] there you see there you
want to go right [ __ ] there right
there you want to go there and nowhere
else you want to go there go there go
there go there now go there go there go
there go there go there jump jump jump
oh my nipples are so hard and crusty why
don't you join me in this bed oh well my
down [ __ ]
pinched down check it now
great dude that's awesome now just go
there yes oh oh I hate this part the
water part sucked I mean you get to see
his butthole
wish I guess supposed to you know it's
pretty cool you know you don't get to
see an AI butthole every day when did
when was the last time you said that to
your mom you know so what are you been
up to
my LA I saw an a huh ai but home oh
that's great honey
so proud of you I am dying here by the
way if you could find a way to get out
at me what is happening which is how
long Artemisa Tarana Oh total Kuno
either Kazi RSI in easy avi what know
what oh [ __ ] no this is the part with
the rap breaks down it gets really taint
10 sending me no Treecko I don't oh no I
mean it was obvious we gonna get
separated at some point but I'm not
emotionally prepared for this Drake off
least I don't have to write a line on
that [ __ ] idiot
I'm kidding
one [ __ ] we're back with the space
technology forgot about it we activated
them I can't wait to know what the story
is or they have some sort of explanation
whoa that's a creepy ass [ __ ] dart is
like a Dark Soul elevator what the [ __ ]
that's so weird and I like it now I'm
back don't like it's cool though it's
very cool all the animation is [ __ ]
incredible
apparently the creator of the game is
like really into that sort of stuff you
can tell
well I think just their level designs
too [ __ ] Corliss
like who would make something like this
I never seen anything like this in a
video game just like a giant ass [ __ ]
beautiful details okay well let's see we
got a progress without that giant son of
a [ __ ] didn't even leave a postcard it
II suppose we can go here I miss him
that's so we I miss him he's not real
but I miss him right go right go mmm
where are you oh can we still this looks
slippery here's the part where I would
have just jumped off okay that's cool
he did it okay let's squeeze through
here okay
oh no we did it so pretty so ready I
feel like this is the kind of game I
would love to just replay just to
experience the atmosphere again it's
just amazing you look at it yes it's
wonky as [ __ ] hell it is wonky
it's no denying that his escape is wonky
I can't [ __ ] you on that one as much
as I love the game okay where are we now
oh it's vine climbing time my favorite
part look at this and they all fall off
it's so cute this doesn't seem safe you
know what I could probably do this cuz
there's water underneath I'm trying to
think like in real life scenarios would
I do this what's with the white balance
on this [ __ ] camera I'm not like
blazing up Jesus Christ oh there's a
pipe Oh drink oh love the pipes or you
[ __ ] idiot take it take the pipe
thank you
you're mrs. dumbest Rico Jesus Christ
half a debauchee drinky-drinky Ricky
that's how you sound like Derrick it
tricky I missed Rico is the real hero of
this story okay let that be known well
we're getting we're getting there
no and bra nice what is supplying here I
don't know if I'm going to like this
what the [ __ ] is that
that's not Rica his tail doesn't look
like that
no it's not Treecko
the music and everything is trying to
trick you that is Treecko but it's not
it's kind of cool though let's check
this out this is pretty why am i walking
so slowly oh it gets quiet
it looks like it's Treecko good
could it be trinka it is not Treecko
everybody pull me for a second no what
Oh
it's the dick Trika the dick oh thank
everyone subscribe 51 million
subscribers we gotta fight him somewhere
always in fighting mode
I recognize when Treecko did this tree
dick move man you know I thought Treecko
was a dick but your dick home how do I
get up yeah okay I did it somehow hey
man
I know you can fly and do all kinds of
[ __ ] but can you do this
suck my balls okay alright just gotta
keep going keep going keep going don't
look down
[ __ ] okay I looked at that's fun you
can't reach you from here oh my god he
can reach me from here can you get up on
it
oh you can't what the [ __ ] am I looking
at okay
he can't reach me from here though haha
dude you can't even do anything you suck
freaka can do all kind of [ __ ] and he's
nice he's friendly we cuddle I bet you
and get any cuddles trying to see if I
can grab on to DS I don't oh okay I got
it
I just jump down here got him let me go
through here yes
this is cool oh [ __ ] he's gonna look at
me hey no no what do I do
oh oh [ __ ] he's good thing is his
dumbest Rico go go go go hoppity well we
did it
alright bad [ __ ]
just go down just go down just go down
you know it's a ladder it's a ladder
what the [ __ ] are you dancing now just
go down still here
be still hear it all he knows [ __ ] I
don't like him I hope it isn't follow us
Jesus Christ all I did was wake him up
from his nap I didn't know that was dude
this is so pretty look at that oh god
I'm gonna die
I can't be serious about jumping down
let's try it that was not it
surprise I got a surprise that was the
name there that'd be cool but I don't
think let's [ __ ] try whoa that's so
cool I didn't think we could do that
okay now one that wasn't what I was
trying to do let me just let that be
clear hit me now thank you appreciate
Jesus Christ oh my lord
how do I get there oh if we can trick
him to go through that hole we can jump
on his face yes that's so cool yes you
don't make oh man okay all right get the
chain thank you lord
Jam did I say Jam I just said Jam thank
you very much
sometimes when I'm nervous I say Jam
okay apparently that's a thing [ __ ]
say [ __ ] - yeah you stay there or you
see so me can't they just be friends huh
maybe it could be a boyfriend your drink
oh I wonder how they probably you know
here we go
hey you Dumbo no no never mind nope
Treecko now would be a great time to
save me didn't it it did did it did it
did it it did to this don't kill me
grab the helmet [ __ ] dude this [ __ ]
hurts this sucks
stop take me up ow ah [ __ ]
where we going the [ __ ] do I do here
huh what happened catechol man
okay still in here where did he go whoa
that's dramatic okay I guess to do this
it seems like a bad idea to follow it I
don't think we have much choice
okay I go that's to be a way out of it
this is stupid
maybe oh yeah I died I died in this cage
that's really dumb RT so cozy on the
couch yuck edie roti oh is he
ah but we're gonna end that episode
there it's the last episode coming up uh
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you in the last episode tomorrow I'm
very excited that should be really fun
see how this wraps up I'm really really
curious I can't wait alright well if you
enjoyed check that out and I'll see you
bros and then x episode there's another
video for you as always
sing out surprised
[Music]